hello and welcome to this video FM
muchacha me which I call me and they're
a name nope not that many feet masters
in Japan if he is indeed Japanese okie
dokie um something else I'm going to
deviate somewhere here maybe I can dash
out the bloomenveldt no always funny now
let's go okay i don't really know Bishop
before that well in this position okay
that's so probably the move closest to
my to my knowledge hmm i have really
forgotten now that it's working ticks
ticks I had that recently in a game with
white I think has somehow stumbled into
that
to create five and i think it was clean
85 but not entirely sure mmm Bishop 86
maybe still might have before hmm okay
okay maybe this and then visual basics
right now the bishop is still hanging
that in on d 2 p-8 does he have c4 maybe
oopy 84mm ropey 335 yeah so not not that
one how to do that here like to get that
blockade I think I think this is move
actually but I don't don't really
remember things I'm kind of making it up
as I go along nightwear b6 ok so
checking them let's go back
hmm i don't want to take the Queen that
much is clear no I want to trade Queens
there and straighten his bone structure
he absolutely insists on trading yeah it
is not a great position it really isn't
okay maybe this for one night a4 and and
c5
prevented that ok I think this is
strategically desirable anyway ok it's
got possible Bishop h3 sometime it
anyway I think I have to do it like good
there okay i can go fish up to see for
so it's still kind of interesting you
should be 4 C 5 you will take my my
bishop but I have Bishop c4
oopsie seven special f5
ta drugs is six doesn't look like how to
play damn
and it's very passive but I couldn't
make the other things work
try to go back to have seven and then
try to use the night later but now it's
not looking great
time warning looks like i'm still alive
my sepan maybe see Paul is dangerous
actually a little bit check I'm
controlling be one so the rook is not so
easily coming back I think I'm better
now unless I'm overlooking stuff c3
mmm yeah he lost the threat that mean it
was it was probably winning for white I
got got quite outplayed they're out of
that opening
yeah you should pierce to give it so
give it up check check we'll go 3s jade
almost made I up to six bloody shy Oh
didn't see it okay
alright it's got two pawns I don't give
me that bloody no dice got two pawns
check check what what she wanted for the
board game an unbeliever stuff resigns
now I came in he got he killed me
completely and then he just blundered
that piece there basically all night
London to see porn and then I'm not
managing the windows end game
unbelievable and I have 30 seconds on
the clock sometimes I should really be
shot for this stuff just something easy
Brooke Brooke 87 or whatever yeah I'm
just aunty otic and he had worked is six
as well let that i blundered anyway
worked his six here and it was
completely unnecessary in the first
place to give him any activity you can
just do whatever you can yeah just go
back on the six rank block block the
porn whatever idiotic yeah anyway so
okay let's have a look at the game yeah
I'll play me very nicely them I mean
that that line I think has a reputation
of being slightly better for white
anyway with the wait when did was really
awful damn that's just a very bad
position I mean
I know I'm sorry that rather than button
I mean this this shouldn't be that
terrible but yeah this is probably
losing a move we are coming before and
have to go to h5 anyway my Bishop b5 is
a good move better than Bishop c4 now
because it covers the pawn that's the
thing computer is not even giving me
such a bad position like minus 0.4 I
mean after that of course I'm okay now
the sea point is more dangerous than the
appointment still it shouldn't shouldn't
be a win button he pledged very
carelessly now and now this is basically
this is over should be okay mean how can
I lose this position I mean sometimes I
simply I always have this kind of
problem that if I'm I'm winning and mean
really really completely winning not
just better that I tend to relax for a
couple of moves and only only then when
it gets tricky i see it when I I make an
effort again and then it was it often
problematic due to time or whatever if I
just mean just something simple yeah
block him here with this and this yeah
block the e pawn bring the King up and
then it's a pretty much easy technical
win there's nothing to worry about and I
really made it far to complicate it in
the first place like this King invade
and so on it was just amazingly bad okay
thanks for watching